is there something you can say about
fundamental principles of judo is there
over all that time
not 20 over 20 years that you've been
doing judo
uh it's not approaching 30 is it
yeah it's it's yeah getting it's going
getting there okay
we're a couple years away let's get in
there
um
is there some like
principles that have emerged like you
said you have to have your center of
gravity below theirs yep is there other
kind of both on the gripping side the
footwork side leverage
anything you can speak to there's some
that
have withstood like time
like you have to be able to get below
their center of gravity because you have
to be able to rotate them
around their center of gravity and then
the other one is
that was always a principle when i was
growing up and i didn't change until
later on in my career was
you have to be able to pull
you need to be able to pull to get them
off balance
but when you think about that statement
as a whole it ended with they have to be
off balance
i don't need the pull to get you off
balance i just need you off balance
and when you think about it that way it
allows you to open up the doors to
what do i need to do to get you off
balance i could push pull i could flinch
i could fake and you could put yourself
in your own off balance state
right when you think about people who
wrestle
right if i fake shoot it causes you to
over lean forward which means you're off
balance
there's no pull there's no push there's
no nothing i just get a reaction
that leaves the opportunity in the door
open for an attack
and that off balance can be very subtle
it could be very subtle and the better
you get and the more skilled you get the
less subtle it is
okay so we should also mention that
there is something called forward throws
where you
throw the person
you know they they're gonna fly
facing forward they're gonna fly forward
and then a backward throw they're going
to fly back yep and then there's lateral
you know they actually go sideways over
like a cartwheel almost
okay so the forward throws there's the
one we've been talking about which is uh
say nagi again there's a bunch of
different variants ippon marota senagi
there's drop and there's standing
versions of them and that all
i don't know if there's a way to
summarize it
but that's like as clean as uh getting
your center of gravity under theirs
as it gets
and then the rest is just gripping
variations yep i guess it's all gripping
variations on all of these throws but um
and then uh there's
uh in terms of forward throws there's
the other big one in competition is
uchumada
which is
i don't know we can try to explain that
one but it uh ends up being where
one or you're standing on just one of
your feet
and the other one is up in the air and i
don't know if you put in that same
category haragoshi like
those kinds of throws where you're kind
of a little bit single footed
yeah so there's two footed techniques
and then there's single-footed yeah oh
goshi where it's like
you're doing a mix between the uchimada
and the senagi
it's a hug
you you hug a person and then you turn
your hips around such that you're now
hugging facing the same direction when
it comes to forward throw there's
regardless of the name of the throw or
the gripping variation that you're using
the whole principle is how do i get this
person to do a forward roll in midair
and land on their back
the more of a forward roll i can get the
bigger the score if i get like
a quarter of a turn where like you land
on your side and you don't go over your
back it's a half score yeah but they all
require me to get you to do that forward
rolling action so just if we think of
one person if they do this nice
leap forward and they do a roll and
they're back nicely rolls over the
ground you're trying to do the exact
same thing with you connected to them
well and if it's nice and it's smooth
it's probably not a full score it needs
to have like
somewhat of a violent impact
right so if you think of a drop saying
agi if i if i'm moving too slow
and you still roll over your shoulders
and there's no direct impact it's only a
half score right they want the force
the force the violence yeah that's good
okay uh so then uh
in terms of uh backward throws
the traditional ones there's stuff where
you trip them
from outside their body like osotogari
it's a trip where you hook your leg onto
their leg and you trip them but your
hook it goes outside of their legs and
then there's the trips from inside
their body there's a one foot is called
kuchi gari
doesn't matter the most important thing
is outside and inside
uh and then there's like i don't even
know how you throw them sideways except
foot sweeps and then there's the foot
sweeps where you can
sweep one of their legs from out of them
or both their legs at the same time
and like we're talking about this kind
of
is when timed perfectly it's it's
effortless for everybody involved and
the ending like you said is big dramatic
and violent yeah
is there other kind of oh oh yeah
there's a sacrifice techniques yep um
there's a bunch of them
and that ultimately the variations have
to do with uh gripping but you're
basically you the attacker fall onto
your back
sticking your legs somewhere on onto
onto their body which is like this
fulcrum over which they fly and do that
same kind of role that you mentioned you
basically sacrifice your back to the mat
in order to throw them into that
circular pattern so they hit their back
sometimes we use a foot sometimes we
don't and so we should probably say
it's okay for you to go onto your back
as long as you're clearly demonstrating
control over the other person's body
correct you can't go to your back in the
same direction that your opponent is
trying to put you to your back right you
have to go the other way or you have to
initiate
you going to your own back
right
uh like clearly and then um
and then there's all the counters which
almost kind of
have a whole group of their own even
though they have
echoes of the same types of techniques
it seems like they're their own whole
thing yeah but they follow the same
principles it's just most
counters like if you wanted to counter
anuchimata for example you're trying to
throw me in a somersault over my right
shoulder
therefore i would counter you by
throwing you over your left shoulder
it goes in the opposite shoulder
direction but in the same somersault
idea
and there used to be i already at this
point forget the years but it might be
20 before the 2012 olympics where they
banned uh you you used to be allowed to
grab legs in the same way you do in
wrestling so you have basically all the
techniques you would have in wrestling
um available to you if you would like
yeah it's just that some of the
techniques in wrestling are not that
effective for getting your opponent your
to their back
wrestlers want to take the other person
down in any way possible and have
control judo wants to take you down like
we said in a big fashion where your back
slams on the ground yeah it has to be to
the back a lot of wrestling takedowns
happen because they get behind them yeah
and then they they part tear out yeah
so uh but judo banned all touching of
the legs which is very dramatic change
at the sport but also 2012. after it was
after 20 it was in 2012 so 2008 i fought
the games and everything was free
in 2012 we could only touch the legs as
a
defensive action or
in response to an attack so i could try
to throw you with a
normal throw
and then when you try to counter i could
grab your leg right
so that there uh had to be a secondary
technique and didn't like didn't they
disqualify
on a first offense first offense was a
direct disqualification which happened
at the 2012 games to the 57 brazilian
who won in 16 yeah she was dq'd and i
think the quarters yeah and it was like
i wouldn't say it was blatant as much as
i don't think the act
changed the outcome of the match had
they not disqualified sure so that's not
that dramatic and by the way you say 57
that refers to weight divisions and
that's in kilograms and kilograms is the
measure of weight that the rest of the
world uses in the united states does not
uh so
and there's uh we should say the
divisions for for guys
um i don't know what the 70 i don't know
slower level 16 60 66 73 and 81 90 100
and heavyweight which has no ceiling
no ceiling
station yeah it is an important
distinction um
so and you competed most of your career
at 81 kilograms all of it
all you never did
never did 73. but you had to cut big for
81 anyway especially towards the end of
my career yeah okay
uh
i overly grew into the division what's
uh uh i'm trying to remember is that
about 180 pounds
178.6 i think and you have to weigh in
with the the ghee no nothing you're not
allowed to wear anything except for your
underwear weigh in sorry confusing
digits so that's right that's right
that's right that's which is very nice
um
okay so we would you say we covered most
of the throws or
no so there's the forward and the
backward there's the sacrifice throws
and the counters yep and the and then
there's the leg grabs and we should say
for the leg grabs that were effective
it's like um
the big pickups where you just kind of
pick them up and try to figure out once
they're in the air what the heck to do
with their body to get them to the
ground you just kind of figure it out as
you go i think the really nice one that
was to me heartbreaking as a fan to see
go is
i guess what's called a fireman's carry
which is uh
you know it does lead to judo like
beautiful throws and the fact that that
was gone is is that one i missed a
little bit but then a bunch of people i
guess came up with the variance where
you don't need to grab the leg
it's definitely not as effective as
being able to grab it but
i'm also on the side of the fence having
competed in all three
it was definitely better for the sport
to remove it
as a whole
it's probably good to cover sort of the
whole spectrum of rules of judo is uh
there's groundwork so there's uh you do
all the stuff on the feet where you're
trying to murder each other with a giant
throw but then you know if the throat
doesn't
succeed you go to the ground and you
stay in the ground for some amount of
time like short amount of time you have
to move quickly you have to be attacking
and
two of the ways you can win
is similar to people who do jiu jitsu's
you can submit them
uh chokes arm breaks all that kind of
stuff no foot locks
and uh
and you can also
pin them yep which is get around their
legs and this is very
no this is not like wrestling you have
to actually get around their legs
and uh pin them in
what indigestion is called side control
mount all kinds of ways that doesn't
involve their legs yeah and then you pin
them for like whatever 20 seconds 25
seconds yep 20 seconds now i think the
distinction is
their back has to be facing the mat
you have to be past their legs and your
chest has to be on the same plane as
theirs yeah so it doesn't have to
necessarily be on top but it has to be
on the same plane yeah and all of this
is
i think
different sports of different versions
of this but it's like
an approximation of what dominance looks
like yeah so pin and wrestling is
dominating your opponent presumably if
you're in a street fight that position
allows you to then do a lot of damage
obviously submissions is dominance
because you're breaking their arm or
choking them to uh
unconscious and then obviously the throw
which is not often
talked about but like if you talk about
a street
fight situation a throw
is like the best way to murder somebody
like this could end anyone's life yes
it's terrifying actually so okay so
these are all elements of dominance
so going back to set of principles
you're mentioning
getting your center of mass under theirs
which i think applies for type of um
like the forward say nagi throws is
there is there other stuff
um obviously you mentioned off balance
yep there's the off balance one where
you can either pull to get an off
balance
or you can give way to the force which
can also lead to an off balance
you can amplify somebody's force to so
for example if you push me
you expect a certain
[Music]
reaction
that you're ready for
but if you push me and i pull you
now you didn't expect that much force
coming out of you therefore you're off
balance
the thing that's distinctly recognizable
about judo
is like when done at the highest level
like it's it seems effortless when the
big throw happens yeah like that's just
it doesn't there is no other sport like
it in the combat sports where
it's like when the timing is right
everything just is perfect i think you
get that mma and um
boxing sometimes when this is a perfect
scout yeah perfect strike just like yeah
where they it but it's not just like a
hard hit it's like
it's almost like the with conor mcgregor
and aldo for example when you just catch
him just right right
and that he didn't look like he hit him
that hard yeah but he hit him just right
yeah and like you get to see this all
the time in judo it's fascinating
you